okay the david pakman show subreddit is
rapidly approaching 14,000 subscribers
one of the largest progressive
independent media subreddits out there
some interesting suppose posts I spotted
this morning at david pakman.com slash
re d di t yes it is official the next
democratic debate debate number three
has been consolidated to one night only
thanks to several candidates who have
ended their campaigns and several
candidates who have not qualified for
debate number three so what we've had
happen between debate 2 and debate 3
first of all five Democratic candidates
ended their campaigns Mike Gravel who
I've interviewed John Hickenlooper jay
Inslee Seth Moulton and most recently
Kirsten Gillibrand have all ended their
presidential campaigns that takes five
away in addition to that billionaire Tom
Styer congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard and
New Age guru and author Marianne
Williamson have failed to qualify for
debate number three because they are
polling below two percent I believe all
three of them had the number of donors
required a hundred and thirty thousand
but none of the three made the polling
requirements and thus they will not be
on the debate stage for debate number
three how long they will continue their
campaigns given that they did not make
the debates I don't know the answer to
so the third debate on September 12th
will be ten candidates all on one night
there's up side and there's downside to
this the upside is when you split the
candidates on two nights you don't get
to see all the candidates interact with
each other so like if Warren and Biden
are on different nights you might glean
that there are differences in policy
between the two but you won't actually
get the opportunity to see them talk to
each other so I like the fact that this
is all going to happen on one night the
downside is that with ten people up on
the stage you are not going to get depth
in any significant way you are not going
to get detail about policy you are not
really going to be able to figure out
who knows three talking points and who
actually understands these issues in any
kind of significant depth but the number
is reducing and we are starting to
whittle down and get closer and closer
to an eventual nominee also from the
david pakman show subreddit
much less serious for sure David Pakman
haircut Semper Fi 2 to 5 says I'm a big
fan of David and I've been watching for
a while
I guess this is a little bit more a
political as I'm curious about what
David tells his barber when he gets his
haircuts first of all how dare you I
don't go to a barber I go to a
hairdresser at a salon not getting a dry
cut are you crazy
I'm half kidding by the way his haircuts
have been on point lately and I would
like to get the same one thanks a lot
all I do I go to the same person what I
found in my experience is that I'm never
thrilled with my haircuts and so when I
find someone that does a satisfactory
haircut I just keep going back to the
same person and I say just the trim
scissors all around no buzzers I used to
get you know like a real high and tight
when I was younger and no more of that
just trim it here's how I comb it here's
where my part is that's all we've got to
do and it seems to be working pretty
well for me so I don't know maybe bring
a picture of me if though you're really
determined to have my hairstyle join the
david pakman show subreddit as you can
see for both serious political
discussion and also nonsense related to
the show at david pakman.com slash read
it it's crazy that this is my job right
I mean it's hard to believe